el siguiente ejercicio nos dice
factorizar el polinomio de abajo como el
producto de dos binomios muy bien y la
clave aquí es notar que ambos términos
tienen a n
uno como factor así que voy a reescribir
lo para poder trabajar con él tenemos n
por n menos uno más tres veces en menos
uno muy bien entonces te invito a que
hagas como siempre una pausa y trates de
resolverlo por tu propia cuenta así que
nosotros vamos a notar como ya dijimos
que n menos uno es un factor que se
encuentra en ambos términos entonces la
idea de esto es factorizar de ambos
términos este digamos binomio que es n
menos 1 verdad entonces vamos a hacer
esto tenemos n menos 1 como factor común
y ahora tenemos que multiplicar a n
menos uno por otra cosa y que nos dé lo
que tenemos del lado izquierdo entonces
esa otra cosa está compuesta primero por
n
aquí tenemos n que multiplica en menos
uno entonces tendremos n y tendremos más
tres verdad así que tendremos que poner
un +3 y aquí tenemos ya la factorización
de la expresión que teníamos arriba
verdad la respuesta correcta sería esta
y podemos confirmarlo
tenemos n que multiplica o más bien
tenemos n 1 que multiplica a n verdad
todo este número multiplica n iv que
corresponde a este primer término y
luego tenemos n 1 que multiplica a 3 y
corresponde a este segundo término así
que la respuesta correcta sería n menos
1 que multiplica a n 3 y ahí acaba el
ejercicio